[Musik]
es ist aus deprimierend schweizer
botschaft zurück schlagen ist selber
schuld oder wir sind es allein gestellt
wie es mit jedem tag ich natürlich der
wunsch endlich eine zielgröße und
deshalb immer belastender die zweiräder
schöne kulisse aber welche stimmung
einfach alle standen druck heitz weller
und nichts wissen das macht dann mach
kaputt
also es ist die eigenverantwortung jedes
mitbürgers dafür zu sorgen dass er so
schnell wie möglich in die schweiz
zurück zu kommen
der bundesrat ruft auf diejenige die in
die schweiz kommen bekommen zu wollen
jetzt zu kommen und nicht noch tage zu
warten
der flugverkehr ist wegen der korona
krise kollabiert tausende schweizer sind
im ausland gestrandet und wollen so
schnell wie möglich nach hause
die frage ist nur wie
[Musik]
die lernmöglichkeiten logistik mit holz
nur die wenigsten mit maske glückscode
jeder lacht redet nicht groß über die -
es ist also schon bewusst dass der eu
minister
es ist so dass die großen werke
untersucht bis wir merkten die schienen
in der ausfahrt worden
nur sechs der luft sind sie also um
einiges ruhiger als in der schweiz
das corona virus ist zum zeitpunkt der
aufnahmen noch kein thema
pauli aber die pandemie ist weltweit auf
dem vormarsch
immer mehr flugverbindungen werden
eingestellt langsam grundsätzlich nicht
mehr unsicherheit ob und wann zu können
also mehr nur zwei mitreisende die namen
locken
als mir ein neues einfach entschieden
dass wir jetzt wirklich zukommt und
jetzt hoffen wir natürlich dass man den
flug nicht
tägliche spaziergang zum beispiel die
frische luft genießen
ja es kommen muss nicht dass es ganz
schön aber dahinter sieht karin hartmann
ist mit ihren eltern und einer tante auf
einer südamerika kreuzfahrt die zwei
wochen dauern sollte
also muss ich jetzt machen
gut eigentlich seit dem letzten sieg
daheim wieder zurück in der schweiz aber
mit dem hit wurde das ganz deutlich vom
netz bis 15 cm celle stattfindet und am
15 märz in eigentlich habe plant in
seinem tun haben der allerdings nicht im
ausland kdh
um mitternacht sind eigentlich alle
hoffe du in amerika geschlossen oder
sogar in südamerika und in den mund
genommen hat die drei sind wir hoffen
und hans themen sprechen können danzig
probieren sie
[Musik]
die baulich urlauber haben angefangen
ihre koffer zu packen
denn sie haben gehört dass der bundesrat
alle schweizer aufgefordert hat nach
hause zu kommen
also haben sie versucht so schnell wie
möglich einen flug in die schweiz zu
bekommen
doch sie haben schnell gemerkt das ist
im moment gar nicht so einfach alles
mögliche kontaktiert die schweizer
botschaft in indonesien den besitzer
singapore airlines ltd
und eigentlich nie richtige antwort über
froh dass so automatische antworten tag
liter seit montag nur schweizer
botschafter flugschreiber jahren ist
sind quasi selber schuld oder mehr sind
es allein gestellt jetzt meinen könnte
wir haben im inselhotel situation user
und das wahrscheinlich das was sie so
verunsichert
es hat sich schon ein werk stand mit
sack und pack unterwegs
aber sie hat die welle machen oder
gemacht
bitte liebe heißt der ironische wies
gestern wirklich so wäre das einzukaufen
und so wie es aussieht sind wir alle
brüder vielleicht strand trotz weiler
und du sicher und die aktuellen und flug
am sonntag aber wer weiß schon wirklich
magath will dann
immer gelungen andy der welt die
protagonistin nimmt den sf reporter noch
ein stück weit mit dann muss er
versuchen alleine weiter zu kommen
lasst euch eine von der größte
supermarkt vor neuseeland vor der
beliebteste produktgruppen momentan wc
papier und also da paradiesische
zustände hinter mir alles voll
kaufen sie die papiere nein
wenn die händler hat maxi ist business
ist quasi unzerstörbar wältring blüht
viel wie und alkohol und schlechten film
und er hat recht
zwei stunden beendet sich dann die welt
und hier eine so routinierte
reservationen gibt aber davon permanent
überlastet
[Musik]
ich tue
15 tage hätten die kreuzfahrt dauern
sollen jetzt ist auch 26 und kein ende
in sicht
[Musik]
münchen strandbesuch konstant ich auch
nicht geglaubt
die stotter im hauptort abzuwarten
das ist mist die neustädter tag wo man
total mit verlag ausgangssperre
die meisten touristen sind abgereist
einer hat unfreiwillig aus dem rückflug
an lokaler information beschlossen halte
ich eigentlich auch zweiter nur gras
passiert wir haben ja auch nicht machen
und es hat weitere steigen wir mit mir
so nervös wie bevor ihm irrt wagen
abgeholt haben
es war glück das mir darüber wo also
exakt wirklich glücklich aber morgen
mache jetzt eventuell den azur und zu
können immer da ist jetzt dran die zu
mir ich fahre oder zwei seeland wohnt
dass ich sechs stunden entfernt geht
jetzt noch längere autofahrt da bin ich
schon wieder falsch
[Musik]
gesund ist attraktiv und peruanische
präsident wundert das ganze und alle
flughafen innerhalb 24 stunden
zurückerwartet wo mir dass deine
erfahrungen im sport immer wieder zurück
ist hast du was information durch sofort
online und dadurch die eltern sofort
online versucht der flug bietet sich
normale focus klima sprechen wir im
moment noch in cusco sind jetzt einige
der hauptstadt
und das ist natürlich den online das nie
funktioniert die verliebten alle
innerhalb kürzester zeit osburg sie und
wir sind der am frühen morgen oder
flughafen aufgaben nicht tatenlos
zusehen möchte sofort der vergangen
denn nach sieben stunden am flughafen
gestanden und hätten versucht wie
verschiedene stellen airlines irgendwie
spiele jetzt behoben in der business
class egal was würdet ihr mann einfach
welle und das hat dann alles nicht
funktioniert sind es überhaupt zu
größeren gesagt dass die flüge für ihn
gebucht sind das ist nämlich anbieter
harfe und den heraus dann entschieden
dass man wieder zurück ist
in peru herrscht seither ausgangssperre
die touristen sind in ihrem hostel
gefangen auf unbestimmte zeit
[Musik]
natürlich dass die ungewissheit dass man
nicht weiß wie schnell ist das ganze wir
sind froh dass jetzt schweizer
botschafter bis er mache nicht mehr
wisse dass es ich bin mir dass man
möglichst schnell holt und das beruhigt
haben natürlich aber das ist trotzdem
war die ungewissheit mit der
peruanischen regierung wolle moment aber
haben die kooperativ sind sie dass man
trotzdem ist auch an wen genau auf mich
den michael hey und das nimmt damals
einfach viel energie weg sind wie
forschungs hier lang da und einfach alle
ständigen druck heizquelle und wissen
wie es weitergeht
das macht dann mach kaputt cool bleiben
und einfach abwarten was passiert
das ist meine ganz gelungen wovon
vormittag mini-fahrer quitte oder daheim
mit dem schuld von russ ist das rennen
plötzlich flog sofort kontakt late call
und das schon am samstag machen
kritisierte vogt uhr aber angehört
je nach lied mit zurück kommt der strom
zwischen richtung zur titelsause sitz
markiert für mehr aber die umleitung ist
so die passieren
so
die ganze familie jetzt ein problem es
gibt es noch
es geht nur im auswurf der karte nicht
geschafft hat so mitternacht wenn jetzt
in marl und morgen der neue akku oder
manchester sind brasilianischem schlafen
einige dem omega früh ins bett gemacht
worden ist für die wbs mitternacht muss
ich nicht man habe jetzt froh bin ich da
noch glücklich gab es mit dem motor die
hat man nicht wie vorgeschrieben und
eben dieser zeit bevor das ich jetzt
schleunigst erlebt als ich irgendwie
daher mit lage ernst und ich sage und
seine mutter sind gerade nach spanien
gezogen als die korona krise kam
überlebten sie das land zu verlassen
inzwischen herrscht ausgangssperre und
spanien ist zurzeit das am schwersten
betroffene land in europa
[Musik]
ja
dazu haben sie den plan tag und san
diego haben wir gut dass man früh kommt
für die schweiz diego den bushof los
angeles und verbaut werden
die allein darum noch zürich wir sind
gespannt wie das ganze ablaufen wird und
damit meint ist ein komisches gefühl
weil mir viel oder wenig sicherer hafen
und wird nach jungkunst die situation in
den geschäftsräumen was man kriegt was
in der schweiz im moment zwar braucht
aber graf freut man sich sicher sie
macht spezielle singapur ist sie das
obwohl die flüge storniert worden sind
hat man online immer noch eine die
kirche war sehr staubig was
unverständlich ist meiner meinung nach
ja jetzt haben wir halt ein flug wunder
über kopf und jetzt geht der plan so
dass man vor auf charterflüge vor dem
ofen doha und von dort anschließen
[Musik]
heute ist taxi zum flughafen
rangnick war froh dass ich hoffe dass
ich außer deprimierend und zweiräder
schöner kulisse aber verstärkt die um
heim nach dazu hatten wir die qual
[Musik]
bremen vorerst salate das ist komisch es
klingen mag die natur
mitglied für wie immer natürlich hat es
bbc geologie wird dieser tage später
wird er die stangen mit jedem tag ist
natürlich der wunsch endlich geheime
zielgröße
und deshalb ist einfach immer mehr
belastende und wir hoffen jetzt
natürlich mega fest das ist eher
rückflug baut stattfinden wird und es
für die meisten ist ein hostel ist jetzt
wichtig dass mehrere zuverlässige
informationen oder spalten mit genaue
informationen zu den flügen und da
zählen wir jetzt natürlich hoffe es
diplomatische können vor der schweizer
flugzeuge hätte ist genug
auch die schweiz fängt nun an sie zu
chartern um ihre bürger nach hause zu
holen
gute nachrichten für die tausenden von
schweizer touristinnen und touristen die
momentan wegen der korona krise im
ausland festsitzen
sie können auf eine baldige heimreise
hoffen für diese leute organisiert jetzt
die schweiz alleine oder zusammen mit
anderen ländern sonderflüge oder
unterstützt kommerzielle flüge die
ersten regierungsflüge sind inzwischen
in zürich gelandet weitere sollen folgen
der sf reporter ist bei seinem schwager
und seine schwester angekommen also
ruhigen flug startet er bestätigt die
schon jetzt unter arbeite ist ihre
sketche das ist ein kurzzeit spiele
wer weiß wie lange das ich jetzt noch
bliebe ja überhaupt wieder stufe die
flug abgesagt werden
[Musik]
also säge zu einem sichtbaren aber nur
von zwei kilogramm
[Musik]
damit die frische luft
camila land gehört angefangen von ihrem
balkon aus konzepte fürs quartier zu
geben
[Musik]
als ich sagte ihm wollte
pünktlich ab kommt
wieso das
gerade dort auf die bremse
statiker zu denken
[Musik]
wird da nur bedingt umgesetzt
jetzt klappt haben es eigentlich immer
so viele schöne passieren tatsächlich
bildet
so jetzt über den flügel dies später
wieder
[Musik]
die einen konnten ihre rückreise selber
organisieren den anderen hat die
fluggesellschaft oder der
reiseveranstalter oder das egal
oder schlicht aus glück
[Musik]
tatsache ist aber auch mehr als
zehntausend schweizer sitzen weiter im
ausland fest
wir sind endlich nach auschwitz noch
regen wir 40 stunden nach der prozedur
sehen wir die zahlen zurückgegangen
es ist willkür und der heimat und alles
gut klappt mit dem wunsch einen
abschluss mit dem flug von london nach
zürich und das gut gegangen ist und
dialog erwartet so um die zehn daheim
und muss mit heimat ist so zog die
schweiz spezielle ankunft
solarwerte mit lustigen texten
[Musik]